First things first
INDIANS >:((
we have managed to fight back
After I reviewed Billion Surprise Toys
I gave it a zero
they have then deleted the video
Victory for the 9 year olds!
Now, if only we can stop T-Series
I will spare any Indian that joins my side
which side of history will you be on?
make your choice
before it's too late
and smash like on this video 😤😤😤
now to something completely different, yay👏👏
handshakes, everybody
how do they work??? :((
I don't know!
clearly I'm not the person to judge here, oKAY?
maybe my track record on handshakes isn't the most flawless thing
but that doesn't mean I don't have the right to laugh and judge other people
failing at handshakes
which is one of my favorite hobbies
so let's feel a lil better on how awkward I am by watching other people being more awkward, yay!! :')
*evil kermit laugh*
*intense music intensifies*
*possible brofist*
*failed*
*the cringe runs deep*
*RIP*
You, you a nobody is gonna hit as hard as life
But it ain't about how hard you hit
It's about how hard you can get hit and keep moving forward
How much you can take and keep moving forward
That's how winnin' is done
*epic cringe music*
*Try not to cringe to this*
*snek in hand confirmed*
*horse skratta*
A'right enough
okay
My favorite thing about Esports isn't how good they are at video games
It's how bad they are at human interactions
(I wouldn't be talking)
cause they are always forced to put that on the test as well
Any time they go against each other, they have to finish off with some form of human interaction
whether it's handshake, whether it's brofist
#notabrofist
whether it's high five
or HUGGING
But rarely r a r e l y it ends well, and it leaves us with an infinite source
of great cringe material
Let's start off
Usually there's an instigator, there's a person that says :
"You two!"
"Shake Hands!"
And they're not ready
They're not ready for it
[host] You boys want a bit of a handshake over the uh
*caption the cringe in the comments*
[triggered] Why did you tell them to handshake?
This is really purely the fault of the host
How can you just assume that they are not gonna mess that up?
[host] bit of a handshake over the uh
I don't even understand what happened, you know?
How do you go from this to -
MOVING ON
[audience claps]
Oh wait this, this is an older but it's a classic
Is that made shot?
[happy music]
Just love how happy they are at the end, you know
Some things, you just gotta work for
The- the reward and payoff isn't there until you've gone through the pain
and Jesus christ was that painful
[happy music]
[RIP headphone users in 3]
[RIP headphone users in 2]
[RIP headphone users in 1]
*how does brad/sive come up with these??*
I think the problem is there's no...
recovery
You mess up
there's no recovery
Unless you dab
backflip or something
I think that's the only redeeming thing you can do
pfffft
What just happened?
*2014 skratta resurrected*
[laughs]
He's clearly going for a handshake
Oh my God
[commentary] I don't know about this guy or his orientation
but Fergus is openly homosexual
okay?
[pewds] okay
So he's going in for the clear handshake
Now let's see where things go from there
wait.. is this Hagrid?
Why is Hagrid commenting over handshakes?
[Hagrid] ...for the cleeear handshake
now let's see where things go from there
Look at this
*cringe alert : ding ding ding*
What a motherfucker!
Oh my Gawwwd
that is absurd dude
that is the most fucked up mix-up I've ever seen!!
and he was not even ready
[repeats] He was not even ready
*heartwarming PDP laughter*
What is happening?
[commentary] Two in a row?
OW
-Oh he's really thinking about it isn't-
Okay they find it, they find it. there it is
*PDP cringe overload*
ugghh
- the crown back on da head
Na nai nananana you don't deserve that crown
That's the king of cringe crown
I feel bad though cuz he tried to make it smooth you know
That's the thing
Can we just not touch each other?
Alright, this was literally yesterday i think
3rd of September, yeah it was literally yesterday
Fortnite summer
the upcoming games fresh cream Lupo he
might be doing well with in-game apparel
he still needs to learn and I kept loop
I'm soon as he failed he just is like no
PICK ONe and COMMIT!!! Ok?? >:((
if you're GONNA do the brofist, do the damn
brofist
I don't even understand how
you mess up a brofist by the way, ok? It's
nearly impossible all you gotta do is
this there's no how hard do I squeeze
let it be known by the way I have an
amazing handshake ok
well- nO ONE ASKED!! You don't even HAVE
hands!
People try now when they meet me
they're like can I please shake your
hand and I'm like yeah you can you
know why ?? this is amazing there was one
little f-king kid in Japan I remember he
tried he tried to trick me that little
Japanese son of a gun
tried to trick me I'm gonna find it where
is it this thing's really good grinds my
gears
oh yeah, this one is great.
*large skratta*
oh I love that one
I just met Pewdiepie and he gave me a
~proper~ handshake. THAT happened. Come on
yeah!! I found it look at this look at
this guy faking me out
he tried-- they're filming I bet he's
telling his friend like alright we're
gonna get him we're gonna get him now we
fight- this is our chance
like I'm crazy
They're conspiring against me!! Okay?
They knew they set
this up alright? I'll film, I'll mess up
the handshake
no. Perfect. You see that?
Perfect
Even though he faked me out, I recovered
Forget the handshake, awkward
hugs is where it at. Please don't do
this to me.
Stop, just- stop. stop.
oh there
it is- with me
*wheeze*
I didn't even know I didn't even know I
thought he meant I should sit down oh
yes that's what you get Conan that's
what you get that's what you get for
messing up my life that's what you get
for ruining my life I'm shaking
I've never been this upset in my life my
mouth is salivating we got a little
sidetracked let's keep watching
ALRIGHT
I DON't ACTUALLY CARE
ShAkE mY hAnD
let me explain what happened here this
guy most likely I'm not saying I'm just
speculating, most likely he has some form
of phobia and he doesn't like touching
people
hence the posture of that you don't
shake my hand this is the posture of I dont want to shake your hand and I dont want to touch,Riiight?
I can respect that but
the reason I know this is cuz I I met a fan
and I was gonna shake his hand all right
this is not a handshake fail by the way
it was a handshake win but I didn't
realize he had some form of phobia cuz
he was wearing gloves
it was clear afterwards cuz marzia saw it
and she told me and she was like he
didn't want to shake your hand cuz he
has the phobia of touching people or
something like that didn't you see he
was wearing gloves and I was like oh yeah
that's right oh I remember he didn't
want me to take his phone
now I remember that's what I IT WASN'T A HANDSHAKE FAIL  tOLd yOu I TolD you I'm so
passionate about this subject hehehehey I love
this clip and I'll tell you why cuz he
just makes a list like a UH hand gesture
it wasn't a handshake gesture so the guy
gets confused and he's like okay thumbs
up to this guy and then he gets confused
and he's like oh do you want to shake my
hand oh wait what but this guy on the
left absolute legend because as this guy
points out he obviously gets a kick over
of awkward this was you know it fuels
some people it gives him strength
it's a buff for him I bet he played
better after this cuz he just dominated
this guy alright what else do we got
oh noΣ(°△°|||)︴
AWWW AWWWWW
this guy is like why are
you touching me HEheHeHe(´ ∀ ` *)
EEHeHEHeeHEEhe LOok aT hIs fAcE
what are you doing＼(〇_ｏ)／
what's wrong with youu(•ิ_•ิ)?
look he's ruBBing his hands  („ಡωಡ„)
hands like I need I need at least
someone to touch him
I just need to get rid of this cringe
please it's a tough life to live I get
it we're all gonna die and here we are
just we can't even touch each other
bla bla bla(ง ื▿ ื)ว
you see an untrained eye might hav-might have
missed that one
I bet an expert level five handshake
failed cringe compilation guy spotted
immediately here you see he goes in and
they kind of wait
bless the man who did the camera work
cuz he spotted it as well he must have
been a very high level rank as well he
cut away from the handshake
to spare this man of the cringe and it
almost got away with it so I applaud
that good job you guys eSports has been
getting really big lately and a lot of
professional video game players are
actually getting pretty famous
here's a guy who goes by the name of
Seagal finishing up an interview at a
competition this week and check out his
cool handshake at the end watch thank
you wait why is Jimmy Fallon stealing my
idea(°ㅂ°╬)
Jimmy Fallon٩(╬ʘ益ʘ╬)۶٩(╬ʘ益ʘ╬)۶
don't make me challenge you٩(╬ʘ益ʘ╬)۶ don't make
me add you to the list of the nine year
olds enemies you know what I bet you
there's some cringe of you Jimmy first
of all this clip is amazing I feel bad
for Seagal though I'm sure he's laughing
at it in his grave because he's dead you
can't survive this quaint
(pewds laughing(*꒦ິ꒳꒦ີ)
if Jimmy Fallon is laughing at you that
that's not you let's say you know you mess up
miss that that's deep
I guess video games help with a hand-eye
coordination but not hand hand
coordination good joke Jimmy who wrote
that for you Jimmy Fallon and shake
failed all right come on give me
something
all right well he's sweating he's got
pit stains so yeah
joke's on you where's this Indian no it's Tai-
Taiwanese shake look at this guy
instigator shake dance visual where is
it where is it
show me the French take me to the cringe
it's sometimes you just gotta throw your
hand out and see where it lands
and so how I touch boobs for the first
time all right moving on wait what is
this handshake fail Indigo Prophecy wait
it fails the handshake I failed the
handshake is the game over
hey games over not an even video games
kid hit look he died wait I play this
game did I that I failed the handshake
ah man
can someone please look that up it's
possible that I didn't even play this
part cuz there's a bunch of different
routes in the game right
oh man please like that yeah you go
forward we go side
that's the thing if you mess up a
handshake new abilities unlock on you
this guy got so angry That's not me
editing that by the way yeah you go
forward we go side all right that's it
that's it that's it for the fresh
handshakes as always if you find them if
you find any cringe send it my way and I
will review it this has been PEeeeewdiEpiee hand shake
the screen right now if you enjoyed the
uh uh Uh uH UH uh